It's like you guys already know Pazookas is discredited. Well,
this Shimu guy thinks Pazookas matters. We got him. We got him.
>> Pazookas is an >> I warned this guy. I told him
there'd be consequences. Why? What? Bro, this is This is the
funny thing is this guy just lies. This will catch up to you.
You can't just do this. Okay, here's the thing. We're going to
press this. We're going to press stuff like this where people
just lie openly, brazenly like this. This guy, Willie Mack, various
other predators, Naku, the like. Okay. Various other people like
this. Not that William Max predator. I don't think he has the
agency for it. Various people like this. Okay, we're just going
to keep pressing them when they lie. They're totally full of
They have no internal monologue. They're just completely malicious
losers that take up space on the internet. We're going to keep
pressing them over and over again on these totally disingenuous
takes on the blatant lies they do to try to stay on top of their
internet careers. Okay, we're just going to keep doing it and
eventually we'll win cuz we're correct.
It's the latest on Ethan Hassan Destiny Arc. I'm not totally
sure, but um I was advised that there's a new Chippy video. Okay,
that might be interesting. Might be a little bit relevant for
the content we're doing today. So, I'm going to do short intermission.
Short intermission and then we will see what else is going on.
We'll take another look. This is where I don't know. I I'm not
sending messages to people. I just said, "Hey, people want to
hop on and chat. They could hop on and chat
if that's what they wanted to do. They could hop on and chat
on Queen said, "Check this video out." So I It's like It's like
hyper related. If it wasn't hyper related, I would probably,
you know, I'd probably not check.
>> It's the sleepy guy. I think this is the guy, right?
Wait, am I crazy?
This is the jaw guy, isn't it? This is a different guy. Oh, no.
This is the jaw guy, isn't it? Yeah, it is. Okay. Okay. I was
like, "Wait, this is the jaw guy, but now it's a VTuber. What's
happening?" It's the same guy. Okay, it's the same guy. It's
the same guy. All right, she's cooked. Denims keeps taking L's.
Let's just check it out real quick. Let's just see what's up.
Why is Denims posing with Nazi leaders to promote her Only Fans?
Asan really letting his fellow leftists get this desperate?
Oh boy. This guy's a commentary YouTuber, okay? He's been posting
about this stuff recently. Oh, we listen.
This guy. We like this guy. All right. We're fans of this guy.
>> Posing with Nazi leaders to promote her own. Hassan
really letting his fellow leftist get this desperate. 4.1K likes.
I honestly should just like completely sell out. Okay. Completely
give up everything I believe in. All right. And just appeal to
either like H3H3's
audience or appeal to Asmin Gold's audience. Option three, I
guess, would be to >> Oh, he didn't want to say what he's
actually doing, which is appealing to Destiny's audience. >> Appeal
to Hassan's audience. But judging by what Denims has to do to
make money to cover for this lawsuit, which is, you know, sell
herself online, I I don't necessarily think that's the route
I want to go down. By the way, Willie M, I think she's just taking
the path of least resistance. Unfortunately for her, there's
just a huge v she's like she is like the kingdom of Saudi Arabia
in many ways. Okay. In many ways, she is able to extract vast
amounts of wealth from nothing. Okay? Just based on her genetics.
Unfortunately for us, you know, if I had the same assets, if
I could do the same thing, I might. All right, I might. Act thought
this was such a banger tweet that he he reposted it. He reposted
his own tweet. Like, this thing came out 17 hours ago and he's
reposting it. Brother, it's not that good of a tweet. Why is
Denims Why is Denims posing with the Nazi leaders to promote
her only fence, dumbass? Look at the It's the court filings for
the lawsuit, you Ethan CL. >> Oh. Oh, good. Oh, good. Oh,
good.
At least somebody else can read and is broadly aware. I love
that he's like, "She's posing with Nazi leaders. Read the filing,
idiot." Yeah. But here's the thing. If if you were if she just
wanted to pose with Nazi leaders or something, wanted to do a
lude with Nazi leaders. Why wouldn't she just get a better picture?
She she could get any picture. Why would she do the lawsuit if
that was her only goal? Obviously, it's to do some commentary
in the lawsuit. Right.
Klein is the one who put these images in the lawsuit. Okay. So,
if you want to if you want to ask questions, take it up with
Ethan Klein. But you're virtue signaling of why is she posing
with Nazi leaders? Brother, give it a rest. That's from Ethan's
court doc. You window licker. That's so funny. Sorry. Her posing
with it is making fun of it. And nowhere near as absurd as the
fact that Ethan put it there to make reference to Hassan. Out
of all, that's Ogre Boy, by the way. Ogre Boy. Infamous.
Infamous. The infamous Ogre Boy. Okay,
kind of dunking totally on Willie here. It's good stuff. >> The
pages from the lawsuit she poses with. She sure got him. Lol.
Bro,
she's promoting her OF. She is literally promoting her OAF. And
I don't know if you noticed. Okay, this for the funny thing is
is why is she promoting her OAF? What is the cause of her why
is she promoting her OF so hard right now? Right? Why is she
doing it? Why is she doing it? It's because she's on the verge
of being financially destitute because of this lawsuit. Right.
Liam Mack has his own and he doesn't want to admit it. He's doubling
down. Yeah. It's very embarrassing. I feel like probably if he
just reached out to anybody, right? If he'd reached out to anyone
and they they could have given him advice, they would have said,
"Hey, just like chill on this, it's probably like it would be
weird to to freak the out over this." But no. Uh people want
to freak the out of this over this. Sorry. And hand denims. By
the way, I'm perfectly willing to point out how people are and
give denims even more money. Yes, just give denims even more
money. I'm fine with that. Okay? If I if I go to point this out
and I don't win the the battle of Twitter ratios, I'm fine with
that. I know I'm right. I know I'm right. And that's why nobody
will engage with me obviously saying, "Yeah, the reason they
use these Alusi photos with Nazis, it's so stupid."
Right? And if I'm going to lose on Twitter, I'm fine cuz it's
going to keep people talking about this. It's going to drive
more money towards Denim's fundraising. Let's go. W Denims. >> 4.1K
likes. More people are probably aware of this image now because
of how provocative it is to use a photo of Gasm Supreme. Okay,
that's why she took the photo. She wants to up the numbers on
the O of make a little bit of money so that she's not in debt
when it comes. I mean, listen, this is a good pick. All right,
what do you want me to say? I believe she also wants to mock
how it was to put pictures of and Himmler in the lawsuit in a
comp so to compare Al Husini to Hassan and Al Husini who you
say Hassan doesn't even work with Nazis. You don't even claim
he works with Nazis, but then to post pictures of Al Husseini
working with Nazis instead of just citing the Wikipedia article.
You just wanted a picture of in this lawsuit. That's it. That's
the only reason. And Willie Mack is straight up defending putting
pictures of in there for no reason. or he's claiming if you read
the lawsuit, you can see it for a good reason, guys. Yeah, this
isn't even capable of reading. Why does he think that we believe
he read this lawsuit?
>> Gamer from Mars had a funny one. What what a disturbing
world that her Sims are probably secretly happy Ethan is suing
the game from work to pay legal fees. The funny thing about Willie
M show is like he he cannot let it go. I I don't understand why.
Um here's what X8 had to say. To be fair, >> dude, him
responding to Connor and being like, "No, if you read the lawsuit,
actually, it's totally fine to do." No, the [__]
>> Pretty obviously meant to show the absurdity of Ethan
Klein including that in a lawsuit about copyright infringement.
By arguing that it's absurd she's showing it, you're making the
argument for her. Why the is that included in this lawsuit? Willie
Max show then goes, "If you read the lawsuit, it seems pretty
obvious that it's there to show Ethan's arguments and the reason
why Snark and Denims hate him so much. If you think her posing
an O of promotion pick with is a W, it can >> that's not
what anybody Nobody is saying. Oh, it's so awesome. I'm going
to go find some Nazi babes on OF who pose with memorabilia. Nobody's
saying that. And trying to misconstrue it as that. Okay. Trying
to misconrue it as as that is so embarrassing and so disingenuous.
But of course, Willie can't read, so Willie will continue to
do this, right? It's unfortunate. >> Certainly be your
opinion, lol. Dude, this guy this guy sucks. All right, first
of all, it's funny. Okay, forget about all the context. This
is funny. Forget about everything. A pretty girl in in a in a
accountant outfit with her leggings up. Okay. All right. With
a photo. This is kind of funny. Am I wrong? Is this not edgy?
Is this not funny? This is not exactly the type of [__]
that Bel Deline was doing a couple years ago. Now, listen. If
you don't like women selling themselves online, if that's the
issue you have, say that. But don't virtue signal. I can't believe
it. She's posing with the German guy. She's I can't believe it.
He's so bad. Like, bro, we get it. We get it, bro. Like, what
do you want? Round of applause. Like, Willie Willie is one step
away from just going, "You guys love what? Why you guys love
so much?" He's one step away from that argument. He's like right
there. He's right on the edge of just being, "You guys, if you
if you all criticize us, you love Actually, you guys just love
>> you're you're the top [__] be making 911
jokes. You know, people be making World War II jokes. Okay. All
of a sudden, somebody you politically disagree with makes a little,
you know, smutty photo. >> Willy Willy Mack is literally
Willy Mack is in the basement, you know, put pushing the elevator
buttons for everybody. Okay. Making sure the elevators go to
the right floor. That's where he is right now. >> With
a you know, like, bro, is it really that deep? >> That's
a Shabascoy comment for anybody who's unaware. Okay. If you think
>> I realize I just said something promotion pick with
a is a W. That can certainly be your opinion, lol. From what
I've heard, it's pretty standard for civil suits like this to
explain why you're the good guy and everyone else is the bad
guy. He's trying to show malicious intent. Is it necessary? Probably
not. Don't see why any of this context would make Denim's posing
with look good, though. Lol. If Willie Max Show could get a million
view video, okay, and all he had to do is film himself like putting
putting Ethan Klein's nut sack in his mouth, he would do it.
He would gobble. Okay. He would
it's so true. It's so true. Oh,
it's we're entering,
guys. People are starting to realize this. And here's the thing.
Willy's fine totally justified to try to come out and make a
video explaining why he is not incorrect here. But he is just
incorrect and he can't identify it. And it's so funny catching
him repeatedly in the with the fact that he has no critical thought
process of his own, that he has no internal monologue, he is
incapable of his own conscious thought, of his own complex thoughts.
It's so funny that a bunch of people are going to start jumping
on board with this. And Rodley, we love to see it. Okay. >> Gobble
like a little turkey. Okay. There is no level to which this little
freak won't sink. Denim's bad. Denim's bad. That's what That's
what everybody says. Everybody says denim's bad. So, denim's
bad. Listen y'all, I find it funny. I I do find it funny that
that Ethan Klein has pushed denims to the point of having to
sell her body even more than she already was. Okay? even more
to a new level to pay for the loss. >> Realistically, I
think this is like broadly the exact same level, but I you know,
it's funny. It's a funny joke. So, we we'll let it go. >> That
is funny. Like, objectively, you look at everything. That's a
funny >> I already hit this guy so much. Wannabe Knucks.
He's not N. Hold on. No, no, no, no, no. This guy's like uh Gigachad,
right? He's got like the jaw. He's the jaw guy. Why has he started
doing this?
>> This is him. He would literally get more views if he
just used his face. I don't know why he used a VTuber. You just
get way more views if you use his face. So, I'm not totally sure
why, but >> that happened. All right. Now, is it is it
fair? Is it is it nice? Is it okay? Probably not. But like, you
can acknowledge something's funny when it's funny. Willie Mac
Show out here being like, "Den's bad, guys. I can't believe I
can't believe this." Like, she's posing with German Gasser. Like,
bro, we get it. Now, here's what you guys are probably here for.
Okay? You guys want me to sh >> Here's the thing. Here's
the thing, though. Okay.
I would honestly be fine if you wanted to say it's so it's so
gross and insensitive for you to talk about you totally disingenuously.
It's totally gross. It's gross. If you also called out Ethan
Klein for it, right? Or Ethan Klein's lawyers. If you want to
say if you want to say that, that's fine, but you can't shut
the up about Ethan and be soy about denims. No, no,
>> All right, let's do it. uh she had a 100k goal, which
by the way, 100k for a lawsuit just really isn't enough. Usually
for these types of lawsuits, if they go to trial, you're looking
at 250K. Like that's the type of numbers that I've been hearing.
Okay, she's only raised 38,000, so no surprise. She's got to
get that. Just for context, when H3 went against Matt Hos, okay,
they raised $170,000
for legal fees. But if we look on the H3 fandom, okay, we can
look back >> there was no accent there. There was no voice
there. You are hallucinating. That is a That is mass hysteria.
Nope. That's mass hysteria. You guys didn't hear >> See
that? Uh Ethan grossly underestimated the cost of his own legal
fees. Uh this was regarding the FUA fund. Cuz remember the idea
was that the $170,000 that they raised. Uh that wasn't supposed
to just be for H3. That was supposed to be, okay, we'll do our
lawsuit and then we're going to create the FUA fund so that anyone
who gets copyright lawsuits against them, okay, we'll fund them.
Um, and obviously that wasn't enough because $54,000
is what cost one month of attorney work for the uh Ethan Klein
case back in the day against Matt Hos. Now, important to remember
this is around 2016 2017 when this is going on. So, you can imagine
inflation all that uh the money is not worth what it is today.
Okay, actually let's see how much 170 back then is worth today.
All right,
>> So, she's not raised enough money. >> It's only
>> I don't know if any of the rest of this video is going
to be good. You don't you don't like
>> a little bit bad. Okay. Is the total >> Sorry.
The rest of this video is probably good. I just I tend to I didn't
mean to say it that way. I do that sometimes. Chip, if you ever
watch this, okay, I apologize. I don't know if the rest of this
video is going to be something I need to watch for like the hundth
time. I've watched so much of this content. I just like getting
the opinions and then I mean, if you're going to cook denims,
I just I'm sorry. I've watched a lot of it. Okay. I used to do
it a lot. I watch a lot of it. This guy is literally being hypocritical
though, calling out. So, okay. Wait, where is he calling? Why
is he being soy? He's going, "You're a loser. You suck." What?
Anyway, we're uh we're good. We're a good chatter chat combo.
Oh, I have the joint chat up. I see. I see. We got it. I was
like, he's not being so This seems like reasonable. Used to watch
a lot of denim stuff, you said. Yeah, I used to watch a bunch
of denim stuff and make fun of people. Do not post Only Fans
links in my chat, weirdos. The are you doing? What the are you
doing? Do not do not
do that. Okay. All right. That was interesting. I think broadly
I think that's going to be an opinion that continues to prevail.
By the way, and we're all good cuz trust, it's a really cool
thing. If you're in like this space where you give like your
opinion on things, if you're correct, it doesn't matter if you're
like a person, right? You're going to win. If you're just a who
everybody can point out how stupid they are, you will lose over
time. And I'm fine with that. them the rules over time. Okay.
How will I max survive this long is a miracle,
but it's not going to go much longer. Okay. All right. What are
we going to do next? The tote the techone stuff. Maybe the techone
stuff. I don't know if I want to do the techone stuff yet. Oh,
hold on. There is a techone piece that I was going to cover this
tweet. I think Teone does a bunch of uh what would you call it?
He he talks more about
the like the whole miskip thing. Oh, he's holding his nukes.
Yeah, Teone talks about why he's holding his nukes.
We're following this developing story. Apparently, Techone, Miskf
going to go to blows at some point. Pause. They're going to go
to blows. They're going to start fighting. Going to start like
trading back and forth some accusations at each other and we'll
see where it goes. He kind of accuses Msk of trying to steal
his friends from him, which is
girl in Austin. >> Oh, hold on. >> Yes. Every Only
Fans girl in Austin.
>> What is the context of that response? I don't know.
>> Yeah. or anybody who didn't like me. Uh, >> has
Miz even said anything? No. Oh,
>> I might have just accident I just accidentally started
up my Twitch stream again. Whoops. Uh, no. I don't think Miz
has said has said much, but Asminold and um Asmin Gold's talked
about it and Miz has getting has gone Miz has gotten gone after
by a whole bunch of the OTK people by like uh NMP just went after
him a couple days ago. A couple people been going after him.
How do you actually start a stream? Uh, accidentally start a
stream. Um, the last thing I touched was my OBS and I hit spacebar
and that automatically selected the button that was highlighted,
which was the start streaming. I think the last thing I'd highlighted
in the OBS window was stop streaming and the start streaming
and stop streaming button are the same thing. So, I hit spacebar
for this to play and it actually started the stream. Boom. That's
how it happened. >> What is this? Oh,
have you been critiquing Power? The most dreaded Nazi of them
all. Contra points SS. What the dude? How are people taking the
contra points thing? I think she has a great position. I think
her what she said was to me seemed like intelligent. I'm like,
"Yeah, I'm totally fine with that." I had no real criticism of
that at all. >> Anyway, back to back to our Techone >> Yep.
Yeah. No, there's been a lot of politicking behind me uh behind
the
>> Yeah. That's that's one of the reasons why I uh
>> Yeah. I I just You know what? And there's a lot of there's
a lot more to this. There's a lot more to this,
but uh no because I can't say his name because then his community
uh will uh just make it more miserable.
but there was a there's >> whose community is well known
for like harassing people who criticize him. Uh is a possibly
tricky question. It's definitely Miz. It's definitely Misk and
the Biz Kids. Definitely 100%. But also, he knows that he's going
to put people onto the bis kids when he says that. So, realistically,
he's saying nothing. He's basically Everybody knows he's talking
about Miskf here. Literally, every single Oh, hey,
Ste going to respond to the Shimu video. That's what I asked.
Definitely not. He's definitely not going to respond to the Shimu
video in any tangible way. But he knows that he's basically
he's invoking misgiv. Everybody knows it. Very few people who
I genuinely love
in this town, but that guy
Yeah, that guy tried to uh take Lucari away from me.
>> That one made me mad. >> Wow.
Wow. >> Made me really mad.
>> Oh, he's so cringe. That one That one made me really
mad. Let me tell you, that's when I knew I was going to come
after this guy at some point. I was mad. You know, I'm your streamer
and I'm You got a big mad streamer over here. I'm big mad.
>> Okay, bro. Okay, bro.
>> Okay, bro.
>> And then there was another guy who tried to get Shina
away from me. Yep. And those two,
I love those two. And that made me mad.
>> I was so mad.
>> Really mad. Yeah. >> Okay. people who are willing.
>> I just this clip alone made me decide that I'm going
to actually watch the Shimu video after this. Like right after
this, I'm going to pull that Shimu video up cuz techone this
loser >> to weaponize lies because they know the truth
I could tell about them would obliterate them at any second.
>> Hold on. Listen again. >> People who are willing
to weaponize lies because they know the truth I could tell about
them would obliterate them at any >> Okay, so tell that
truth. Why Why are you like holding cards here? Why are you holding
cards? This is so cringe, dude. >> And one day I will,
and I look forward to that day, but it's not the time. I'm a
very angry man, guys. I'm a very, very, very bitter, angry man.
>> H, this reminds me of that other stream he did where
he's complaining about his girlfriend. He's like, "You're going
to see what happens when you aggro, you've awoken the demon.
Uh, you you thought you thought you were around with a nice guy.
Well, you're [__] around with a demon. I'm I'm really
mad now." Dude, shut the up and do something like make a statement.
do anything tangible.
He's so He's so and weird and gross. Like I Dude,
this guy Oh, just wait until we We're going to watch a Shimu
video. It's going to put But we're It's going to put it all in
perspective. He just lies about everything. He just lies and
lies and lies and lies. Is weird. Okay, remember when he said
he was going to solve everything with his ex with receipts and
then he posted no receipts and didn't comment? Remember that?
And then now he'll just say, "Well, I already proved that was
wrong." No, you didn't. No, you didn't. The [__]
are you >> Oh, yeah.
>> Oh, man. >> Just like Rich Campbell, except Rich
Campbell, when he didn't when he didn't immediately do it, shut
the up and got off the internet. Okay. Rich Campbell didn't continue
to harass the people who were accusing him of things. Rich Campbell
didn't go live every day and go, "Oh, I'm such a victim." He
shut his mouth and left. Thank God. I love Rich Campbell. Okay.
Rich Campbell should be uncancled just because he showed how
when you do get canceled and you maybe think you up in some way,
you want to handle it correctly. He walked away. Bring him back.
Bring him back now. Okay. At least he just shut his mouth and
he walked away for two seconds. He didn't sit there saying what
a victim he is all the time. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I have a lot to be angry
>> He just went live with Mia. What? >> That's the
reason why I keep my stream
It's just It's disgusting.
It is. It's a disgusting pathetic world. >> It was the
It's a disgusting pathetic world. These people are all gross.
They lie about me. Everybody lies about me. I'm so disgusted
with this world. I don't even know why I do this sometimes. I
don't know why I'm still in it. I don't know why I'm still in
it, guys. I don't know. It's just a disgusting
sick world out there. All right. I think this clip may be decide.
We didn't finish the whole the whole thing, guys. We watched
an hour of the Nick Fenna's interview. We will do the the next
hour, next stream, but I think I'm going to go on to the techone
video because I just watched him talk and now I want to watch
Shimu, you know. Light him the up. Light him the up, Shimu. I
have a lot of faith in this video. Okay. Oh, wait. Hold on. I'll
do I'll do 30 seconds. I just need to grab some more water. Sorry,
I'm going through a lot of water. I've been yelling a lot. Hold
on. Actually, I might be able to start the Shimu video. I think
I do a minute of this Shimu video. Yeah, cuz Shimu is going to
get you guys up to date with the old stuff anyway. I do like
a minute of this. I'll be right back. I'll hit play on this.
Okay, I'll bring I'll I'll be right back. Two seconds. >> There's
this one guy. There's this one guy. His name's uh Shamu. So,
this guy's accusing me of being a He wanted me and Trevor to
make out in front of him. We kissed. His lips were so chapped.
My stubble on his stubble. We got naked. >> Hello everyone.
So, there's been a few things that have happened in the fallout
of the TechTon doc I thought were worth talking about. I also
received a return on the foyer and the 82 pages of court documents
referenced in my video of Techon's insane lawsuit between his
ex-wife and ex-girlfriend. If you haven't seen the first video,
be sure to check it out as you'll have more context for some
of the things being discussed. I'll put a link in the description.
Also, please hit the like button and leave a comment as it helps
with the algorithm. Also, if you want to support more videos
like this, I'll throw the relevant links up on screen. One of
the main criticisms of tech
Not a great start. Not a great start. Not a great Willie Mack
moment. Okay. Willie Mack moment. Unfortunate. Unlucky.
Quite bad.
Okay. Okay.
All right. Um, what was I saying? Support Shimu. I put the the
video link in the uh I put the video link. I pinned it. Okay.
There's the video link right there. You need to write up a program
to monitor. No, I have the flashing thing. I just don't look
when I come back once in a while. That's my bad. That's just
my bad. I up. Okay. Anyway, he says Shimu accused him of being
a Now, if I'm if I'm not mistaken, I do not believe Shimu's ever
said he's a I think maybe at most there was like the inconsistency
on Molly pointed out, but I don't even know if that was pointed
out in the previous video. I don't know what she said. Techad,
sir. Sorry. Question like that better for Discord or something
where I can respond later. He just said he liked Shoda. Well,
he I think he did say that before and he also has liked some.
He also has liked some literally. Okay. Wait, he did? Well, he
has liked some. He absolutely has liked some on Twitter before.
That is just a fact. Okay. I don't know if that's going to be
late on this video. I don't believe it was laid out on the previous
video, but my favorite part of this video is going to be this
one. Okay. Tech's response to the prior video. That will be good.
Anyway, we're we're still in the intro. Support Shimu. Let's
get let's just get into it, okay? Cuz we we love watching Teone
getting his just deserves >> is when being criticized,
he constantly sympathy farms his audience. Here is how Tone responded
to the internet making fun of his father being an infamous convicted
military pest. Something he was already well aware of. >> I
was named after my father's best friend because I was supposed
to die at birth and I was just considered the failure of the
family. I was I'll be real. I was never really treated too good.
My father threw me to the ground, put a against my head and he
said, "Give me a good reason not to you."
>> Wow. What a great response to Hassan laughing at you
for your dad getting convicted of crimes in the military. Huh?
Guys, I've Guys, he tried to kill me and I was >> hated
my father. He never told me that he was proud of me. >> He
even references this reaction as a quote play, as in implementing
strategy and talking about the father pest response stream the
next day. >> What they'll do is is they'll hear me say
that I don't care and they'll see me crying and they'll post
that. But I think it was a I still think it was a good play.
I do. I mean, obviously it wasn't pre-auth
yes. I think it was a good play, guys. It was a good play, right?
That was a good play to go and cry on stream about all this stuff
totally unrelated to Hassan and then blame Hassan for it. Wasn't
that a good play? >> Overwhelmed by, you know, obviously
I get sensitive about my family 100%. But >> so let's consider
these things when viewing the ball. >> 2 minutes after
my premiere on Tech finished airing, he immediately would go
on to Twitter and post what many suspected as sympathy for me.
Quote, "Rest in peace, Christy.
>> I forgot about this one." Yeah, this was weird, too.
Now, you can't for sure call this out as sympathy farming because
of Shimu's video, but the timing is so suspicious and weird.
She passed away like days earlier. You were like me and >> I
I wouldn't make this accusation quite so strongly, but >> kindest
person I've ever met. I'll miss you forever and I love you. People
DM'd me letting me know it was posted and at first I thought,
"Yeah, I don't know about that. It's a bit too conspiratorial,
even if a bit coincidental." I said I would have to see if the
person didn't pass that day in order to consider it. It's an
odd coincidence for him to post this just 10 minutes after my
premiere ended, but you need more. Well, people were actually
able to find online that this person >> Oh, it's Freddy
Woods. I know this guy. Liar caught in the act. Uh, very convenient
that somebody just post this for Shimu to throw in the >> had
actually not passed that day, but well over a week ago. Since
the tweet was framed in a way that would make the reader think
that she passed that day and it was just 10 minutes after the
prego,
there's a chance he was sympathy farming. As I've already established,
this is a key trait Tectton has and utilizes when operating online.
One thing you have to realize about Tee is that he is hyperfixated
and paranoid about videos being critical of him and negative
coverage. If you go to any video like this, >> yes.
Yes, we have established, guys, we've helped establish the narrative
here. This is this is the Pazooka stuff. This is our
Yes. >> You are likely to see Techone commenting on the
video sometimes immediately after they go up. videos with two
interviews to a couple thousand will often have. >> Tecton
goes off the deep. That's a ramen. That's one of ours.
Soon you will understand too my child. >> Tecton there
commenting on it. This man >> he does it everywhere all
over the place. He is ill. >> Bigly and is watching the
vast majority of videos and cover. >> Oh, there he is on
a queen video. I don't know, man. I think Tetoad is pretty cool.
>> He received Tech respond by saying people were attacking
his friend's mother that passed away and that they were saying
he was making it up. But that wasn't the point anyone was making
at all. The point was the timing of the post coupled with the
video and her passing well over a week prior. Things would get
even stranger when Tecton would respond to all this by saying
he was having schizophrenic hallucinations seeing this woman's
spirit in the room, vaguely addressing why he made the post about
this woman a week later while also claiming that he was paying
this woman. >> Wait, I didn't see this part and life >> Uh,
broine God himself. Oh, I was hallucinating like crazy yesterday.
That was I had I was a
>> What? I feel like that's a sentence I've never said.
I was hallucinating like crazy. You're just showing up for streaming
like, "What's up, guys? What's up, chat?" Yeah, I was hallucinating
like crazy yesterday. Were you on drugs? No. No.
I should be, but no. >> I was sitting on this couch when
I heard the news about Christy passing. And uh my OBS was open
cuz I was talking to Shina while trying to get my stream set
up. I swear to God, Christy was behind me. Sometimes I can't
tell if I'm a schizophrenic or if I'm a shaman. Uh honestly,
it's a tossup. Yo, guys, what do you think? Anyways, lightning
totem, fire totem. Uh, in case you guys don't know, my best friend's
mom died around 8 days ago. My buddy wasn't really ready to talk
to me about it until like 2 days ago, and then I got him on the
call yesterday to actually find out what happened cuz he told
me there was bad news. And uh, I actually was helping pay.
Now, the weird thing about this is he might not have been ready
to talk about it, but I could have sworn that we had from the
Freddy Woods thing. Was that not May 24th? Is this not Would
this not be of my mom Chris? Would this not be the friend talking
about it on May 24th? What do you mean? His his friend wasn't
ready to talk about it at all. There's bad news. It's literally
on his Facebook page. He literally made a post about it. Is it
likely that he'd just go, "It's bad news." when he made a public
post. Is this This seems totally totally made up, right?
Why the would this guy Why the would this guy say, "Oh man, I
don't know. This is really bad news." Maybe he doesn't want to
talk in detail. Sure, maybe he doesn't want to talk in detail.
Okay. But why would he be like, "No, there's bad news. I don't
really want to say anything." When he made a public post, that
don't make any sense at all. >> I had I was sometimes I
can't tell if I'm in case you guys don't know to actually find
out what happened. He told me there was bad news. And uh I actually
was helping pay for the uh life support of Christy um for a bit
there because uh she she was more to a mom to me than my actual
mom was. It could totally be coincidental that he made the post
accidentally making it. >> See, I was I was I understand
this could be a thing here. Oh, is Shimu about to make my argument?
Hold on. Gather says at Jtock, if he's paying for the mom to
stay alive, how wouldn't he know when she died? Uh, I truly believe
that these people make so much money that they do not pay attention
to their finances. One iota. They just got a guy who pays attention.
He wouldn't even know, right? Having like paying for it, I don't
I don't think he would necessarily know for sure. That's That's
way easier to understand for me than him just being like, "Yeah,
my friend told me about it, but you said there's bad news. You
didn't want to talk about it." Actually, that's odd. >> My
actual mom was. >> It could totally be coincidental that
he made the post accidentally making it look like she had just
passed away around 10 to 20 minutes after the premiere finished.
But again, I find it odd that it would take over a week for Tee
to find out about this, especially when according to him, this
woman was more of a mom to him than his own mother. If you recall,
one of the lesserknown secrets about Tech was his inability to
have for the vast majority of his 10ear relationship with his
ex-wife Free and the totality of Pink's 2-year relationship with
him. >> That'sed up. That'sed up Shimu. I don't know why
that is a intro to this. That doesn't make sense to me as an
intro to this next section at all.
This guy's doesn't work. This doesn't work at all. Why? Wait,
why? Why' you do that? That's crazy. vast majority of his 10ear
relationship with his ex-wife and the totality of Pink's 2ear
relationship with him. >> You understand why I would not
have with you as a victim of assault and myself. I had trauma
when it came to having this is a known fact. I have told you
this from day one. I don't want to apologize for being and being
scared. >> So, I did find it. >> I don't think that's
what she was asking for. I I don't think she said he her. I but
I think it was like you was forced or uh like coerced oral, right?
>> Funny when opening his response stream to my video that
I was greeted with Teone over compensating and announcing to
his audience that he had been having a ton of >> I just
passed the out dude like I mean oh Jesus
>> I was just having so much
I could just I just passed out. Okay, this more seems like possibly
this seems like it could be a bit. This seems like it could be
a bit, I think. All right. >> Oh, no. I just blew my load.
>> Technone is deathly afraid to review the video and most
likely never will on stream. Inside his Discord, if you even
attempt to post any video tangentally related to mine, you will
be banned from posting. So, the only reason Tech had any comments
about my video whatsoever was because the XOTK member Justin
Minkx or Minkx on Twitter shared the video and said, "Just a
reminder, this dude supports his father who is a rap and got
an anime tattoo to feel better after assaulting and degrading
his past two partners, but okay. I've had bad interactions with
him myself in private, but this video will really shine some
light to viewers." >> Like the other day where he posts
about Minkx going in about me about my quote unquote allegations,
right? Oh, here we go again. Yeah, those things that are obviously
those are very serious even though it's been over a year and
nothing >> I mean something has >> Wait, what? Wait,
if nothing's happened then why can't you talk about it? It can't
be that nothing's happened and you can't talk about it. Oh, it's
been over a year and nothing's happened. Either something's happening
or you could talk about it.
Why does he undercut himself? >> Stone himself has stated
he is being investigated 100% and has been in contact with the
police. >> I'll be real. I went to the police yesterday,
right? Cuz like you know they're going to investigate me. They're
going to investigate me 100%. They're going to investigate me.
They're going to investigate me 100%. Anybody's worked with the
police, it is so
slow. It's
>> I think we uh I think we pointed Shimu to this stream.
I think Shimu had not seen this stream before. We showed him
this one. Okay, this is a good one. This is a banger stream.
>> Oh, look at this. Makes shots post this weird ass. This
the worst hit piece. >> It's the worst hit. >> It's
that the hit piece like a shot hit piece. It's like actually
such a good That's such a good video. It's really a shame. I
don't know what its view count is at, but its view count is not
high enough. If it doesn't have like 30,000 views, it's not high
enough. Okay, 23,000.
It's honestly from like a bigger creator, probably a 100,000
view video. It's a really good video, but obviously Shimoo's,
you know, 4.8K, 23K video. That's pretty good numbers. Putting
up numbers on that one. Okay, that's good numbers. Let's go.
Anyway, we go back. piece, but Tekken refuses to watch it or
any of the numerous people that have covered it. Even banning
his Discord members from being able to post anything related
to it in his Discord. If it's comically bad, Tech could pick
it apart, but he never will because he has no explanation nor
any good answers to the questions that the video poses. One of
my main criticisms of Tecton is he is a prolific liar, which
>> we'll see plenty of today. >> So, this one guy,
this one guy,
what's his name? I forget the guy's name. >> No, you don't.
No, you don't. No, you don't. He doesn't forget anybody's name.
If it's Shimu, he doesn't forget Shimu.
I think it's somebody else. >> Something moo. >> So,
right. >> Oh, no. He does. He knows exactly who Shimu is.
>> Way. The guy literally just had my video on screen,
but is such a dishonest coward. He has to pretend not to know
who I am after I've talked with him directly and his worst enemies
have been reviewing my video for the past week.
>> I I don't know. This guy DMs me being like, "Uh, so,
Mr. Teto, sir, Mr. Protective, sir, may I get a couple questions
uh about what's going on with your current uh issues with your
exes? >> I told him I would be covering all of his recent
controversies with his father and ex partners because I wanted
to be >> Hold on. Hold on. Is he criticizing Shimu for
reaching out preemptively and not just running a hit piece on
him? Is that the criticism? Oh, this little reached out to me
for comment before he just published a bunch of about me. What?
Like that's maybe the worst criticism you could possibly give.
Yeah. You don't even get You'd never get that courtesy from YouTubers.
Like that almost never happens. Even though it should, right?
Yeah. If if this guy didn't reach out, you go, "Oh, I could have
just cleared this up and you didn't even reach out for comment.
What a disgusting loser."
>> God, we
I don't know. This guy DMs me being like, "Uh, so Mr. Tech, sir,
Mr. Tech, sir, may I get a couple questions uh about what's going
on with your current uh issues with your exes?" I told him I
would be covering all of his recent controversies with his father
and exartners because I wanted to be sure to include his side
for context. All the questions I laid out were the most critical
criticisms I had for TechOne or lies I felt I had caught him
in. >> And I'm like, "Yeah, sure. I can answer anything
that you want me to answer." And then he sends me like the most
inflammatory questions of all time. And I'm like, "Okay, well,
I can't answer these, but if you wait a little bit and you wait
for the results of the investigation that is currently ongoing,
then you'll have your answers." The majority of these questions
he had already talked about publicly. I asked why he hadn't filed
a defamation case. If there was a period of time Pink wasn't
paying rent, if there were any other receipts he had posted so
I could be sure to include those in the video, his ex's lawsuit.
The revenge his wife was accused of spreading that is now considered
false by both parties. And if his ex-wife had ever planned on
making allegations against him. >> Dude, I went to get
>> there was a period of time Pink was never mind. I'm
not I'm not even going to I'm not even going to comment. Okay.
None of these are blocked by a lawsuit is my point. God damn
it. there were any other receipts he had posted so I could be
sure to include those in the video. His ex's lawsuit, the revenge
his wife was accused of spreading that is now considered false
by both parties. And if his ex-wife had ever planned on making
allegations against him, one of only two questions he answered
is a verifiable tech.
Thank you for the 13 months. And also,
I'll just stop on I'll just stop muting. I don't even care. >> What's
the worst what's the downside? What's the worst possible thing
that could happen? I'll just stop muting. And the other was included
in the last video twice when questioning if he had encouraged
Pink to go after his ex-wife with legal cases and revenge
>> So if you want to wait a little bit before you make
your video, that way you can actually be informed. Bada bing,
bada boom, there you go. And he's like, Teto trying to avoid
my questions and silence me from making the video. >> I
did not say he was trying to silence me, but I did say he was
lowkey asking me not to make the video, which I do >> which
is literally why does it need to be made now? You're literally
saying wait to make the video. Don't make the video right now.
is probably the fairest criticisms he offers as it's self- admittedly
a bit overdramatic. That being said, this is like 5 seconds of
an hourong video. There is a ton of criticisms and lies I caught
in that video. So, it's telling this is one of the few points
he's willing to bring up at all. >> And then the guy goes
live with an hour and 8 minute video of the most dog bad faith
arguments I've ever seen in my entire life. And then he starts
my face expressions and my body language and saying, "You see,
he's lying because look at how his eyebrow twitches here."
>> Dude, I feel like if Shimu did that, I would have been
like, "What the are you doing?"
I don't recall for sure,
but I feel like I would not have thought that was such a good
hit piece if that was like a significant thing Shimu ever did.
Did he? Did he? I don't think he did that. I'm pretty sure he
didn't do that. I I feel like Shimu is just gonna deny. >> So,
this is the first outright lie by Tech. I never say you can tell
he is lying by reading his facial expressions. >> I'm not
even sure if I make any conclusions whatsoever over his facial
expressions. I do close-ups on important moments to add entertainment
or to make it dramatic. But what he just said never happens in
the video. It's just a lie. >> Then he gets plazookas.
He gets plazookas
as a viable source of information. This is the Oh, Teone has
to go after Dude, the fact that Teto knows who Pazookas is is
embarrassing. Okay. The fact that Tee comments on old Pazooka's
videos is double embarrassing.
The idea that he would use Pazookas or Pazooka's commentary to
try to like, oh, I can't I can't discredit Shimu. You can see
what's happening, right? He has no actual criticisms of Shimu's
video, or else he would have brought them up first. So, now he's
gonna be like, you guys know who Pazuka. You guys remember Pazooka
is my biggest hater. by totally deranged schizophrenic hater.
Right? You guys remember that guy, right? Well, this Shimu guy
thinks he's really smart. Oh my god, we got him. >> The
other outright lie tecton tries to >> It's so lazy. It's
just a lazy webbing thing, right? It's just the It's just lazy
webbing. He's like, "You guys already know Pizookas is discredited."
Well, this Shimoo guy thinks Pazookas matters. We got him. We
got him. >> Pizookas is an Alog channel of Techone, but
I only use his videos as an archive for a stream Tech and his
archive channel deleted. minus one comment made. Pizookus never
speaks in the video. It's just using the archive. At the end
of the video, I have an archive thanks because I always thank
the creators platforms or users that archive things. But outside
of this comment and >> and she went after his wife and
there was a whole controversy over that she basically protected
him, defended him and he used her constantly.
>> That's like barely even opinion. That's like almost
entirely fact. You could say, well, constantly is subject to
like um like it's an opinion or it's a what do you call it? It's
like subject to interpretation, right? How old is this guy? I
think Pazook is like 50, 55,
I think. Yeah, subject to interpretation. And Teone would know
that. Techone would see that, right? If he watched the video,
why are you making criticisms? Or he didn't watch the video.
He's speaking out of his ass.
Certainly looks terrible either way. >> Never comes up
in the video. But Teto wants to exaggerate this to manipulate
his audience. >> This guy is 58 years old. This guy is
58 years old. I you not. Every single day he makes a video about
me. He even put his oneyear anniversary of making video. >> This
guy retired early and he was like, "You know what? You know what?
My kids go to school still. My wife's at work. I'm going to sit
at home and watch this Teone guy and just tell everybody how
terrible he is every single day." That's such a massive W. It's
hard to understate. Okay,
sorry. It's hard to overstate. It's hard to overstate how much
of a massive W that is. This guy's just sitting here retired
watching Techone all day. It's fantastic. >> On me uh with
the most skitso takes ever. And here's the guy he's listening
>> It's actually incredible that one of my main criticisms
of Techone was him. >> Wait, hold on. Or was he talking
about Shimu? Cuz I've noticed this. A bunch of people think Shimu
is literally Ben Thorp because I think his avatar is Ben Thorp,
right? I think he might be saying Shimu is
50. And I don't know if Shimu knows this. I don't know if Shimu
is actually 50. Oh, it's Coach Red Pill. Right, right, right.
It's Coach Red Pill. Yeah,
but he makes videos on the Thorps as well. It is Coach Red Pill.
But does he think this guy does he think that's Shimu? That's
funny. Him lying and manipulary
of making videos on me. The most skitso takes ever. And here's
the guy he's listening to. It's actually incredible that one
of my >> and here's the guy he's listening to. >> I
mean, >> oh no, it's probably it probably is Pazookas actually.
>> The tech tone was him lying and manipulating his audience
and in himself he's actually doing it. I've never spoken to bizookas
and outside of a single archive there's really nothing >> He's
a 58year-old man who accidentally doxed himself, leaked all of
his private information. So,
>> oh,
he is talking about bazookas. What the is this? Every sing doesn't
every creator know online like why would you say this? You know,
does he not realize he's literally going, "Guys, guys, guys,
this guy who harasses me, this 58-year-old loser that you should
totally go after, okay, he doxed himself. You just got to look
a little bit for it. This is doxing by proxy. It is doxing by
proxy. You could maybe argue he's enough, but I think he's like
he's one of those people who's like unaware of how self victimizing
he is. He's like so narcissistic. He doesn't even see what he's
doing. He knows it's like it's below uh it's above subliminal
and it's below like liinal. Okay. It's like he he is doing it
intentionally somehow without totally being Oh, I don't care.
No, no, no. Brazilian lad. No, no, no, no. Don't say that. Don't
say that. Oh, sorry. You're making a comment. Either way, I wasn't
sure what you were saying. Okay, it's fine. It's fine. He's like
I almost want to give him that I don't necessarily think that
he knows quite how bad what he's doing is, but also I feel like
he knows somewhere in his heart that he knows 100%. Like I I
don't even know that I can give him the charity anymore. I want
to be able to give people charity on this, but this is I don't
think so, man. He's just blatantly saying, "Yeah, this this guy's
doxed. Go find his info if you want." I've done the favor of
not talking about him for a year because if you want his full
name and address, it's already out there on the >> Never
mind. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. This is
totally malicious. This is insanely malicious.
The [__] is wrong with this [__] Dude,
what? This guy's like one step below Dean Withers right now >> for
a year because if you want his full name and address, it's already
out there on the internet. So, I don't talk about him ever because
this already happened. People already looked into his background.
People already looked up that he has multiple diagnosed mental
illnesses, right? >> I really, >> dude, dude, this
guy's psychotic.
This guy is actually psychotic. I feel like I'm bordering there
on being like Pizookas might have a case
to like go after him for this and be like, he's totally violating
the community guidelines in a deranged way. Why the would you
do that? This guy's insane. Tech is insane. >> This guy
may be the most deceptive person I've ever covered. It is so
obvious he's attempting to tie me to someone his audience is
primed to regard as mentally ill in order to try to discredit
me essentially beyond. >> Wow. I wonder where he may have
picked that technique up from. I've heard of this technique before.
Oh my god. >> Totally fake here. Techone is also malicious.
He made sure to tell his audience, "Hey, this old man's docs
is out there, just so you all while framing it as if he is doing
what's best for someone he obviously deeply dislikes talking
about him. And for the record, I have zero clue if any of the
things Teone is saying about Pazookas are true here. As my last
two videos demonstrated, Teone be lying a whole lot. It's already
been stated, but I've never spoken with Pazookas, nor did I get
his testimony from my last video in any way. To me, though, it
just seems like he's just another guy a logging someone. That's
why I called him the quote resident techone a log in my last
>> I've warned this guy to stop making content about me.
He still does it. And they're using this guy. >> I What
did you warn him to stop making? What?
I warned this guy. I told him there'd be consequences. Why? What?
Bro
is a credible source where all he says is the women are telling
the truth and techone's lying even though I've proved >> That
never happens in the video. Yeah, that obviously didn't. See,
this is this is the funny thing is this guy just lies. This will
catch up to you. You can't just do this. Okay, here's the thing.
We're going to press this. We're going to press stuff like this
where people just lie openly, brazenly like this. This guy, Willie
Mack, various other predators, Maku, the like. Okay. Various
other people like this. Not that Willy M's predator. I don't
think he has the agency for it. Various people like this, okay?
We're just going to keep pressing them. When they lie, they're
totally full of They have no internal monologue. They're just
completely malicious losers that take up space on the internet.
We're going to keep pressing them over and over again on these
totally disingenuous takes on the blatant lies they do to try
to stay on top of their internet careers. Okay? We're just going
to keep doing it and eventually we'll win cuz we're correct.
That's what it is. >> Everything cuz there's this narrative
going around me which is Tech Jones used an NDA to silence up
one of his exes. >> No, we don't know why the NDA was signed.
The only thing we do know is that it was sometime around when
his ex-girlfriend was suing his wife after discovering his ex-wife
was going to go public with allegations against Teetone. You
cannot make definitive statements though. We as the viewers do
not know what happened. The point was to look at the timeline
and contradictions or outright lies Tee made. That does not mean
we know definitively if Tee is guilty of all these things. Yeah,
I think we said that when we read this like no matter what we
we don't have like definitive answers on things, but that's why
Shimu
obviously this leans in a direction, right? It seems to lean
in a direction, but Shimu went to Tee and was like, "Hey, can
I get a comment on you?" Cuz like, I would like to have a fair
video. And Teone didn't respond. Teone just didn't respond at
all. He's been accused of just that as viewers, these are things
that should be considered. >> And it's like, first of all,
I was the one who was placed under NDA. >> This guy, man,
he's something else. You both were placed under NDA. There's
no definitive statement made by me about why you were. only that
it followed shortly after she was going to make an abuse accusations
public. There could be some mutual reason, I suppose, but it
went from ex-wife is about to drop a Google doc detailing your
abuse to lawsuits and false police reports against her and then
the Google doc being silenced and NDAs being up, >> right?
I didn't go towards anybody and place them underneath an NDA.
That's not a thing that happened. That's never a thing that happened.
And the other thing that happened is you cannot NDA a crime.
You cannot do that. That's a thing >> you can't you can't
India a crime >> that you cannot do. >> Right. So
this is true but it literally does not change the fact that she
was going to make allegations which you lied to me and to everybody.
>> It's basically oh man how do you put it? You can't a
crime which is true but it could be under some other there's
like an adjacent thing where it's like you're making a vague
allegation and you could kind of misrepresent these circumstances
like oh if we can prove that this is like false you could be
sued back. I don't know. I don't know. It's in any case, I do
not believe that I do not believe Shimu ever claimed he knew
a crime happened that was getting indaid. It was like so people
wouldn't talk about the allegations she was going to make else
about. Separating the insane thumbnails for a second, these videos
are mainly to illustrate how TechOne lies because those are the
things that can be proven which should cause skepticism when
looking at a timeline of events and his narratives. >> So
my dad, right, my dad um man, people really like talking about
my dad. So this is the last thing Tecton talks about in regards
to the video and it is interesting. One of the criticisms I levy
at Tecton was >> okay you can't NDA crime but you can NDA
speaking about it. So you can't make public statements but if
you wanted to go file a lawsuit or file a criminal complaint
you could do so. So you could say well public statements about
it are wrong but you can't stop them from um yeah maybe Brazilian
lad as well. Interesting interesting >> was the performance
he gave after his father's drama blew up. He basically threw
him under the bus. talked about how his father was putting a
gun to his head, abusing him, and his father was being quote
a monster. >> It's kind of hard to think of your family
as a monster. >> However, after watching the video, now
he will be defending his father. >> But I got sent an article
about what it was that he actually did because everybody was
telling me, >> "Uh, dude, it's not even the tears. It's
the little like it's like the the breaths in, right? Those like
rapid breaths in. That's the one that's the that's the thing
that like I'm like >> me that my father was a and uh you
know everybody kept on saying oh dude your your dad's a dad's
and >> technically my dad was only convicted of harassment
on multiple counts and assault on multiple counts. Okay.
Technically he didn't actually penetrate somebody. So it's not
really >> I'm sure at this point at this time you guys
have probably heard that right? I'm sure at this point you guys
probably heard this. Well, I actually got sent an article of
what he actually did. The judge found him not guilty of the most
serious charges of assault, which would have required him to
register as a sexual offender. But yeah, so like >> but
I think so there probably are some versions of assault that make
you register as offender, but I believe he was still found guilty
of assault. No, it would have been a lesser degree. >> I
don't know why everybody's calling my dad a when he didn't even
anybody. >> So take the lines a bit here, but his father
was charged with assault and harassment. The controversy for
his father was that he was >> oh assault and harassment.
So perhaps not assault sex and that when these people came out
with allegations, he was tried in a military court and was given
what politicians at the time would have regarded as a sweetheart
deal. Basically, he was able to keep his pension, stay off the
registry, and get off light. This is why his father was the poster
child for the quote stop military initiative that was going on
at the time and televised on C-SPAN. But yes, he was never accused
of force penetration and I don't believe Tecton believes that
was ever the case either. Also, the article Teone uses as proof
people lied about his father is the same article I used in my
last video. He just doesn't read the rest of the article where
after his father is found guilty, he tries to approach the women
and say sorry and they run away crying from him. >> So,
like,
guys, let's uh let's cut that part out, guys. We don't want to
put that in the
>> Why is everybody calling him a rap? And according to
this, he didn't even touch anybody. So, this is untrue. He was
charged with assault. He just wasn't charged with more serious
ones that would have led to him being a sex offender. I will,
however, say this is a much better response than his first one
where he called his father an abusive monster that threatened
him when he was younger with taking him out with a firearm. That
being said, if it was me, I would probably never address it after
the first time. Just >> Yeah, that's the thing. That's
what it seems like to me, extore, is they wanted to they don't
want him registering the defense offender registry, right? They
don't want that smoke. They don't want those headlines. say,
"Yeah, it happened." And then move on. >> So he was a gooner
and he had on his government computer and he showed it to people,
right? So like at least like if you can't do the bare minimum
of research for that. >> Oh, uh-oh. It's going to have
other allegations in that, right? Or other things that he was
found to like found to have done, right? Oh no. Are we going
to get the transcripts? Are we going to get people describing
exactly what Iron Mike did? >> I mean, I don't know what
you want me to say, right? You've got to sort of admire how dumb
this guy thinks his own audience is. He's literally using the
article specifically from my video. That's probably where he
found it as I did not see it anywhere else during the scandal.
Then he has the gull to partially present it and hope his audience
don't look into it at all. Considering he watched the video and
this was the only response he could muster, I feel even more
confident with the lies pointed out in the previous video and
its accuracy. >> So he was a gooner. >> Tech cannot
stand.
Oh no,
guys. Just let him goon. Just what is it? A crime to be a gooner
nowadays? A crime to be a gooner? Really? We're going to act
like a like nobody else goons out here, guys.
>> It when people make negative content about him back
in the >> He's a fan of Arsenal. True. I forgot about that.
That black guy who got caught by Chris Hansen. >> Impact
days. He basically had a long string of bullying autistic game
meta people for simply saying Tectton's takes weren't backed
by any of the mathematics they used to determine optimal strategy.
Techn was so butth hurt about this he likens the criticism to
people trying to ruin his life. >> So you think that my
takes are good? >> I don't know. I don't think your t No.
Oh my god. No. But >> so it's not a joke. >> I know.
Do you think me insulting like saying your Genchin tanks aren't
good is does that hurt you? >> Do you think that when my
livelihood
was to make
No way.
Your takes aren't good. Uh, you're just going to come after my
livelihood now. You think this is a joke? >> Make money
off of YouTube. Do you think when I was $1.1 million in debt?
Do you think that when the ent is he? There's no way he's referring
to a mortgage right there. Is he as $1.1 million in debt? A mortgage
for the house that he lives in. He's just going to say when I
was $1.1 million in debt. That's like technically correct in
some ways, but you have an asset that offsets that debt, right?
You don't buy a house and you're in like massive debt immediately.
It's not like it's not like that necessarily. Okay. Oh, wait,
wait. Miscip did loan him the money though for the down payment,
but not 1.1 million, but not 1.1 million. Like, he would have
had the asset still. And depending on when he got that asset,
it might have appreciated significantly. >> Higher Genchin
community was >> probably not at this time though. You
think me saying, "Oh, great. Another had made a video on me.
I can't wait to deal with the backlash." When I had no money,
when I was about to lose, Dude, this actually totally explains
why he handles criticism the way he does, right? Like, this is
what he was doing with random YouTubers who are like, "Actually,
this guy's tank isn't mathematically correct. That he's going
to like bring them on and bully them and say, "Oh, what are you
trying to like you're trying to like actually bankrupt me? You're
trying to like run me out of house at home right now. That is
kind of how he seems to see all criticism is like attacks on
him personally. Well, attacks on him and like his livelihood.
It's like, bro, how about you just stop being a piece of on the
internet? Super easy. >> This is my house. What do you
think that was going to do? You can paint it any way that you
want. You can say, look at how much of a silly Billy I was being.
The reality is you caused a lot of damage. I was going to say
cuz he said I'm ruined I ruined his life and like the video hurt
him and stuff but like he was being super nice to me in DM. So
like are you what >> and I felt really I felt really bad.
>> Tech is >> these people are are like giga autistic
like the Genchin spreadsheet people >> be an idiot offering
how he feels about what's best when you have these mega autist
doing spreadsheets of frame data and mathematics to determine
what's optimal. This would be fine, but of course tech would
get insect
these creators and lie to his audience tactics like saying things
like he dismantled our argument in two minutes using in-game
data and logic. >> Even when other content creators came
on my channel, like when Jing Jinx and Tuner came on my channel,
bro, I dismantled him in seconds and he had to spend 40 minutes
trying to justify his cause, right? Y'all were there for that.
I dismantled him in second. >> Dude, it's so gay that people
can do this. They can just go like, "Yeah, I'm right." No, remember
that guy sucks. I was right. I'm correct. I'm correct. I'm correct.
Right. And then people just believe them for no because they're
just
oh, it's brutal. >> I have a been able to defend. >> By
the way, this guy was the still the biggest Genchin creator after
this. Nothing nothing bad ever happened with >> every single
one of my opinions beyond a shadow of a doubt using literally
in-game data and logic, >> which you can easily see is
not what happened if you actually just went and watched the VOD
of the actual discussion. However, he is the bigger content creator,
so he can rewrite history as much as he wants and say whatever
he wants. and he knows that his viewers aren't going to bother
going back and actually looking at the VA of this discussion
and seeing that all of his claims are. And in a he said he said
situation, the bigger content creator always wins. That was Jing
Jinx. And Teone had a whole drama with him over his Jeang Lee
metatakes. To add insult to injury, Tecton would later admit
that he knew he was wrong, but as he so often does, just completely
lied to them and his audience. >> Now, no way.
No him. >> Let's just call a spade a spade. Do I think
Jean Lee was good pre-buff? No. Will I ever admit that to another
content creator? Absolutely not. Good god, man. >> Is a
guy who wants to be the base right like his hero Oz.
Dude, this guy is this guy got to go. This guy got to go. All
right. Insulting an only fans girl is one thing. But bullying
random autistic spreadsheet nerds in a gotcha game, that's where
we draw the line, boys. That's where we draw the line. You bullying
You're bullying one of us. Okay, you're bullying one of us. This
is
Get this guy out of here.
>> Good god, man. >> Is a guy who wants to be the
base right like his hero Osman Gold, but the come Shimu, I'm
I'm repping you here and you say Osman gold. I'm repping you
on stream. I'm saying sub to this guy. Like the video. I linked
your Patreon the other day and you you put this video out and
you say Osman gold. Really? >> Truth of the matter is he's
a degenerate addictive freak. So he will lie deceive even change
his views or principles based off what benefits him at any given
time. None of this is more apparent than when he decided to go
after lollycons because Tone himself has a history of liking
lolliccons and talking about characters that went as low as 6
to 8 years old while ranking them in a waifu tier list. >> Next
up, Palon. Dude, I feel like if Palon were to visit me, I feel
like we'd just be best friends, you know? And I bet she would
taste delicious. Imagine how Pon's feet would taste when she's
18. probably like cinnamon and honey. Uh, should be fine. B4.
I can't believe she's not butter. Awful. Chi-chi. S tier. Adorable.
Okay. Oh, I didn't know there's more to this clip. Oh my god,
there's more to the clip. Hilarious. Cute. Get this girl a Cocoa
Goat. Okay. She is adorable. She is beautiful. Dude, this girl
is already running a hotel at like age six in patch 2.0 know
when we gather the dragon balls and we revive Chi-Chi and then
she gets to expand to level 18 and age 18. >> Why? Why?
You were doing so good. You're doing so good for so long and
then you had to go here. Why did you say this? Why did you just
Why? >> Imagine how amazing she would be. >> Techone
also openly talked about having
crushes on lolly characters.
>> want to punch you in the face now. because you make
me feel feminine.
You make me feel like a little You make me feel like I'm a little
kid back in middle school. They have a crush on you and it's
not healthy. >> Now, I want to make this totally clear
that the creator Techone tried to deplatform was certainly more
of an
>> Oh, I don't know why the announcement Oh, there he is.
Okay.
Jesus. Uh, Queen, thanks for the raid, buddy. Thank you. Thank
you. Welcome, Queen Viewers. We're catching the end of the the
second half of the TechTone video right now. Okay, we watched
the first half. This guy is this guy's sick and he's got to go.
All right, welcome welcome raiders in >> case without a
doubt 100%. But it is the hypocrisy that I feel is worth addressing.
Tecton actively consumed and profited from this type of content.
However, he would try to deplatform other Genchin creators or
in some cases the exact same things he had done like having lollies
in a waifu tier list. If you were to report a crime to a police
officer, that would not be considered drama. This is calling
out some disgusting behavior because I have never seen anybody
be this blatant of a file in my whole life on YouTube.
This is like I I I will almost wrap around I can't quite wrap
around because of like the actual like serious allegations. This
almost wraps around to being so shameless. I could almost respect
it again. Almost. He's just so disgusting in general. I can't
quite get there, but holy, this is some insanely shameless behavior.
>> No ass
if you're into you got it with Nita. She she doing wonders for
you. So, I just wholeheartedly think both of them are smashable.
>> So, I want to make this very clear. It's a little little
harsher than the language he used, but still to go from from
where he was making one of these tier lists to full-blown this
guy's that's pretty crazy. >> Ro is doing a Genchin Impact's
most breedable character tier list and puts and let me just go
ahead and show you puts Nita and Cle and Diona in S tier. Imagine
how Pimon's feet would taste. >> Would attempt to
>> Uh-huh. cancel this other Genchin Impact creator for
doing in some cases the same sort of ranking tier list he himself
did in the past. While Ren had much more explicit behaviors,
>> I will say yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay. I was going to say,
all right, this guy the other one is worse obviously, but it
seems crazy to try to cancel this guy. >> The ranking of
Wallies in a Waifu or breed tier list in my opinion is within
the same realm. Tecton would then post about how the creator
should be deplatformed on Twitter, but delete the post soon after
because people began going through his Twitter and finding all
of the Lollcon artists he was following. Tecton was also called
out for sing for a trans lolly that is 15 and talking about the
character openly on Twitter. They also had Teone like
I know where that's going. I've had that album on screen before.
Oh boy. Hold on. We'll listen. 15 and talking about the character
openly on Twitter. They also had Tecton liking post with this
lolly character getting plowed by some black furry creature.
So needless to say, he was busted again for >> by the way.
Just I don't even know want to zoom in necessarily, but yeah,
that is what's going here. He's love he's liking like hentai
of this character. >> A liar. After being caught in 4K,
Tecton would panic and mass unfollow every account he had previously
been following. However, afterwards he immediately followed lolli
accounts directly after posturing such as the anime man which
is this guy. You see, Tekken doesn't even really hold this as
a principle. He regularlyates with famously associated with Shadman
at one time. Shadman is famous for creating depictions of real
children doing explicit acts.
>> Uh just pull up the [__] weird Liy Arya
getting [__] by a dog thumbnail that he used. That's
what you should actually pull up here. >> He famously used
Keemstar's own children for one of these disgusting depictions.
Naku. Also, >> I don't like playing like multi. Yeah, there
we go. Oh, wait. That's not Ari Stark. I thought it was Arya
Stark, but yes, this is a lolly getting by a dog in in this thumbnail.
There's like actual hentai of a lolly girl getting by a dog.
>> Viewed lollycon and all sorts of things on his own YouTube
channel. Point is, Tee happily associates with people like this
and has admitted as much. >> I agree. I agree. I I do think
it's a little bit hypocritical of me to follow people who I know
like lollies. I definitely think that's hypocritical. But the
thing is, Ji is one of the reasons why I started
>> hypocritical of me to follow people who I know like
lollies. I definitely think that's hypocritical. But the thing
is, I >> Joe's one of the reasons why I started YouTube
and Lucari's one of my best friends. So, he's going to have to
overlook it sometimes. Just to be completely honest, I agree.
This guy's the most disgusting piece of [__] in the
world. Lucari Well, Lucari's black. Loi is our form of reparations.
Okay, it's the weeb reparations.
Black people just get to like like lolly. Okay, that's how it
is. >> That is completely hypocritical. >> Essentially,
Teone tried to deplatform a competitor in the Genchin Impact
space. He admits he still follows all of these other people that
are into loi and he's on recording ranking toddlers as waifuss
and talking about them in a manner. So why would Tekon associate,
work with, and be okay with some lolly people but not others?
>> I'm not going to sit here and turn a blind eye. This
is not normal behavior. This is deranged. Imagine how Pimon's
feet would taste >> in the past, >> bro. Teone should
have just he should have just shut the up. I don't know why he
threatened to sue Shimu or talked about suing Shimu. Totally
>> totally
and surprise surprise has lied to do so. Tekken will pretend
that he didn't know what Loi meant in the past and then Boldface
lie that he only said the word one time, quoting another streamer.
Here he is lying to another streamer straight to their face.
>> Bro, these guys are the people in a mental asylum. Bro,
>> what the >> I said the word loi one time because
in the game's code, Cle and Chi-Chi's body type, they're underneath
the category of Lai. So I said the word lolli and what thing
is I was quoting another content creator named X likes who's
a good dude. >> Okay. But him him and this other guy called
Fob say the word lolly a lot. I don't. Right. So I said it for
the first >> Is that the bad part of liking lolli or engaging
in any kind of like lolly fantasy is whether or not you use the
word. I would think it's the of childlike features. I would think
that's probably the bad thing. Not whether or not you use the
word. Bro, >> it gets clipped and people say that I'm a
pedophile. Shaw is like this little lolli girl. Okay. She's a
firefighter. Uh doesn't look like any of them have miniguns,
which really me off cuz I want a insane lolli with a minigun.
Uh we also have flame. >> I don't use that word guy. That
word that word would be weird. That's weird >> Whose kid
seems pretty weird, but I don't care cuz he looks really hot.
The the K-pop lead singer haircut. And then Vermemelly, the little
the little lolly girl. Please give me zombie lolly. Oh, zombie
lolli. Please.
We need dead zombie lolli
and we need big daddy dogger. No new. Let's go. Cuz I said the
word cuz I said the word and they say I'm a my little >> This
guy's like the most disingenuous
dishonest piece of It's very very funny. It's funny having just
someone to go over it now. Okay. Who's not Pazookas, I guess.
Although we love Pizookas. Listen, Pazookas owns this guy in
every possible way. I don't know why we got to I don't want to
downplay Pizookas. If Pazookas has some history of mental illness,
then you know what? Okay. Despite being despite having challenges,
he still totally read and understood Teone and exposed him for
what he is. Okay. W [__] bazookas. >> Sister
sees that [__] without context. >> And then
I have to explain to her why I'm not a group.
>> Yeah. So they're really just on your for no reason.
>> Yep. Imagine how Pimon's feet would >> In summation,
Teone is fake and doesn't stand on business if he can benefit.
One guy makes a lolly breed tier list. >> I glad I'm so
glad that Shimuk keeps using that clip because technically in
that clip he goes when she's 18. I want him to actually take
to Twitter, okay, and make that defense. I want him to make that
defense so badly for him to go to Twitter and go, "What I said
when she was 18, guys, I said her feet would take how how would
her feet taste when she was 18." Guys, I I hope that that's why
he keeps clipping it right there, so that Tekken will be like,
he's hiding the context from you guys. Okay, let me show you
the context where I say explicitly that the feet would only taste
good once this six-year-old was 18. Can you believe this, guys?
Can you believe how these guys lie about me? I'd never lie to
you like this. >> Teone tries to deplatform him for being
a nun. And the other guy is literally playing explicit videos
with child characters since they're just enough for YouTube.
And Teone's cool with it because he's a big name. Tecton actually
reviews an extremely mild video on the Nux Taku drama where he
puts on a sweeping clinic for KN, calling the Shadman situation
a non-issue several >> Uh, the Shadman thing was a non-issue.
>> One point he even had direct contact with Shad where
multiple >> fair. This is another non-issue. Oh, since
the beginning of me and Nu's friendship relationship, maybe four
years, 4 and 1/2 years, he's been nothing but good to me. I think
it's fine if people don't like Knucks. I think that's completely
fine. However, I don't, so I really don't care. Uh, that's pretty
much it. All right, cool. Like, comment, subscribe. >> Now,
let's get into the court papers. They were filed June 25th, 2024.
Before delving into them, it's important to remember that this
is Techone and his then girlfriend Pinkside, which will look
to paint frame in the worst possible light. 2 months after this
>> wait, what did he call her? >> 2024. Before delving
into them, it's important to remember that this is Techone and
his then girlfriend Pinkside, which will look >> Pink Sai.
I've never heard that >> to paint in the worst possible
light. 2 months after this filing, Bream would deny every allegation
made within these court papers and demand a trial. 3 months after
this and Pink would respond asking to dissolve the case with
a notice of non-suit with prejudice where both parties would
bear their own costs and attorney fees. So, we should remember
that when this was contested to go to trial, dropped the lawsuit
and came out saying the most damning allegations in the suit
were false. So people can read through the filings and come to
their own conclusions. All the >> I believe she also said
I believe there's additional information now that she says techone
told me made me believe that this was true. >> Filings
will appear on screen for viewers to read, but there were specific
points I will hit so this doesn't go on forever. The first page
is standard with Pink seeking monetary relief of over $250,000
but no more than a million. The next two pages explain Mythic
Talent and their roster of Asmin Gold, Miskf, Teone, and others.
It states that Free assisted Tecton with daily management of
Tectton's brand and business and that she was the head artist
of Mythic talent and worked as a designer for OTK and Mythic.
Now, part of this I had in my last video, but what I didn't have,
which further proves one of Tecton's lies, it states that Kerism
was hired on July 25th, 2022. This date is important because
Tecton had claimed to pink and the public threw her that the
reason Tone verbally abused his wife in the car >> was
because Kerm and his wife had che that he found out his wife
was cheating on him with Kerm. But the curs guy, they hadn't
even met >> car was because he found was cheating on him
right before this car domestic. >> Keep bits of mind. This
is the day he caught her and Cruz cuddling on the couch and realized
they were cheat she was cheating on him with Cruz, his >> However,
this July 2022 date is months and months after this. It also
corresponds with the plane tickets Pink had posted as proof to
prove Tecton was lying about this. And these court documents
further corroborate the date of Kersam's arrival, further cementing
one of Tecton's lies. Exhibit one is attached to this page's
claims about Kerism and Free going on dates. Couple interesting
tidbits about this one. The person who leaked all of her private
communication with Free to Tech is Vtuber Kittenetic.
Interestingly, half a year later, Kittenetic would be one of
the people backing up both Free and Pink publicly about Teone
being abusive. The other thing I know is just that this
>> Dude, are Tek and Desty just the same person? This is
Are we going to find out that this guy's like secretly recording
people drinks in like the next year or two? Are these like the
exact same? >> This was made well after Free and Technone
separated in September. Page five elaborates more on the date
Kurszman Free went on and then further states Free would separate
from Teone leaving 8 days after this filing for divorce 4 months
later. The next page states Pink and Teto began dating in December
of 2022 and provides Twitter logs to corroborate the timeline.
Given its validity, the exhibit does suggest that Pink Chu and
Tech began talking a month after Frame filed for divorce. It
then gets into the revenge allegations which Pink now denies
ever existed. The only evidence provided is a still the front
yard of Pink Chu and Tech getting into the car. Now, this is
tricky, but it's specifically >> I asked I asked uh Shimu
and hopefully maybe at some point. Apparently, he does go through
basically all of it and it looks like he goes through quite a
bit. >> He's narring it as well or he's narrating it as
well. Angry Way thing for the 15 months, I think. Um, as we go
through this, I
am very interested, okay, in like reading this in full and like
actually digesting the information. >> He states there
were cameras around the house. I'm assuming since the only evidence
is of the front yard that these cameras were around the outside
of the house, but this is never clarified in the filing. Tect
states on the next page that his ex-wife called him and said,
quote, "Is she better than me?" and told him about the cameras
and that she cheated on Tone while they were still living together.
Then there's a bunch of high school drama about who is dating
who and rumors being >> and who is >> one of
gag.
>> Teone was grooming Pinky Shu as a slave due to her autism.
What after te trying to tamp down any rumors spread by Frame.
The rumor mill started turning at full speed. From January 2023
to August 2023, disgusting lies were spread about Pink Chu and
Tecton. Those lies included Tecton cheating on Frame with Pinkchu.
Pinku was a home record that broke up the marriage of Freeman
Teone. Pingshu has several cosmetic surgeries and was considering
more such as gag reflex surgery and Tectto was paying for them
and Tectto was grooming Pingchu as a slave due to her autism.
What is gag reflex surgery? I have no idea but we should consult
Willie Mack because he almost certainly has it. Okay. >> Reflex
surgery is one I had no idea even existed until reading this
court filing. It also mentions the micro comment Free made about
microone. As a quick aside, in the last video, I didn't think
much of these comments other than Techton's ex just talking poorly
about him. But I was made aware that he has actually openly talked
about having a micro before. So I'm leaning more towards microphone,
not being just a meme. >> That's what women do when I pull
out my
>> They say, "Wow, so small." >> That's my That's
my ritual. I wake up, I up, and I go do my job. >> Uh,
but I woke up. >> Sorry to that. >> I'm going to
say that I get how you might make these. Okay. I get how you
might make these comments in in the course of doing like the
what do you call it? The like degenerate content or something.
I I tend to just believe it because it's funny, but it's >> And
then I I covered it up as me scratching my leg. Thankfully, I
have a very small cop. >> Call it a stereotype. >> What
does he need gag reflex surgery for? Uh, she needs it. And obviously,
it's because
not for him. >> Call it unfortunate circumstances, but
being a self-admitted microone ain't helping his abuse allegations,
fam. If you're keeping score, you can put a point in the dip
category for this one. Next, I mention one.
>> Abuse allegations, fam. If you're keeping a score, you
can put a point in the dip category for this.
>> Next, I mentioned one of Tecton's friends, Zizzix. Presented
as someone who knows all the allegedly illegal things Scream
is doing to Teeone. For those who don't know, Zizzix is a guy
who upon Pikachu making allegations public, potentially spread
fake DMs of Pink to try to discredit her. He claims he didn't
know that they were fake after being called out for it, but you
can decide that on your own. I'm kind of 50/50 on it. Tecton
also claims his ex-wife sent videos to Kinetic and the CEO of
Mythic Talent. Nexfream is accused of posting Tectton's bank
statements, stealing money, and a whole host of things. However,
the exhibits that are provided to prove these claims contain
none of that info whatsoever. Page 10 states that on February
3rd, Free announced that she was not on good terms with Tee and
there were current legal happenings between them and their lawyers.
Then on page 11, the next day, it gets back to Pink that Free
was about to go public with allegations against Teone. It stated
as quote, serious and false allegations that upon hearing them
from Peak, Teone freaked out. He found out that a Google doc
was about to be released regarding the abuse allegations and
that vbeco
and sodapoppin were aware of the alleged abuse. >> We had
these screenshots in the previous video as well. >> Claims
it was being used as blackmail immediately after this in the
court >> I googled it. It involves either both removing
the u entirely. It's the thing at the back of your throat and
reposit repositioning the pallet. Oh, >> it states that
in response to these allegations potentially becoming public,
Kinchu then elects to file a police report against free and for
revenge. It then claims that people that used to employ Fre were
sent revenge. But again, Pinkchu claims this revenge never
>> Bro, what? >> That she was manipulated to press
charges against Free to silence her. So, if this is true, what
the hell is going on with Fream's former employers who were representing
Teto at the time and still are presently. Let's take a moment
to consider a few things. One, Pink and Te are alleging in this
that Fe was just willy-nilly spreading revenge of them to hires
and co-workers at the org she worked for at the time. How deranged
does it sound on the face of it? Oh, hey boss and CEO of mythic
talent, Mousashi that pays my bills. Man, me and my new boyfriend
are furious at my ex-husband and his new girlfriend like you
wouldn't believe.
You see, Tech Hey, Tones Tech's agent. You want to see his Hello.
Hello. >> Here, let me just send >> Yeah. Yeah. Check
that out. >> Check out a microphone. >> I have of
them that I secretly recorded on security cameras. It sounds
insane. Mythic Talon is a talent agency of mostly YouTubers with
other people signed such as Techone and Osmanold. Pretty good
agency, especially if you're willing to be on the record. >> I
need that to stop. I need that to stop. I need that to stop.
I need that to stop.
>> Revenge from your employees and potentially later going
to court for it. There's no documentation whatsoever or statement
from Mythic Talent CEO or employees if any of this happened.
by the way. So I suppose the question would be if we are assuming
these are lies if M talent was aware that they were being named
as a witness to revenge point crimes that never happened. How
involved were they were helping push a lawsuit in favor of two
of the people they were representing at the time pink and techone?
Those are the only two options. Either Free sent all of her co-workers
and her boss, the CEO of Mythic Talent Mousashi, revenge her
ex-husband and his new girlfriend, or they knowingly lied about
receiving it in order to aid two of the creators they were representing
at the time. We know it's stated in the court document. >> Well,
I sorry. Did he cover? I wasn't necessarily paying the best attention.
Did he say like I understand those are the two possibilities,
but like maybe they just haven't commented on because they never
had to. You defoyed these documents, so maybe they just alleged
this and because it never went anywhere, it doesn't matter. >> Free
was telling other creators a part of this network about her alleged
abuse from Techone. So, how much was there to gain in participating
in a lawsuit or the police action that occurred right after these
allegations got back to everyone and were about to become public?
And can you guess who Mythic Talon is owned by? The same company
that has had several of these sorts of allegations in the past.
OTK or one true king founded by OTK members Asmin Gold and Tips
Out, who you can see here with Techone on the Steak and Eggs
podcast. Two, the VTuber who leaked all of her communications
with Free, Kitnetic, was the main source they used throughout
this with leaked private conversations of Free venting to what
appears to be a friend. The odd thing about this is that months
later when Pink came out with her allegations against Tectton,
Hitnetic tweeted in support of both women claiming they had the
exact same story as far as the abuse they experienced with Teone.
After Pink made it public that the revenge wasn't real, there
has been no clarification from any of these supposed witnesses
in regards to any of this as so far as saying, "Hey, she's lying
or or anything else." Thinking this was strange, I reached out
to Kinetic, who actually responded to me in the exact same way.
Why is there a random Why is there a random howling mutant tweet
on stream here? PV, you're a black guy on Junth and you see me
observing you through your kitchen window and letting you know
I'm one of the good ones.
>> She said that they would talk about this subject, but
because there was a lawsuit, they couldn't. However, there is
no lawsuit. And I was able to get her to clarify after I mentioned
the police investigation that that's actually what she meant.
Basically, I was told what was stated publicly is all that can
be really said out of fear of the ongoing police investigation
or any potential legal fallout. I wish I could give a clearer
answer as the >> that doesn't make any sense at all. >> Implications
of the revenge from being a lie are actually pretty massive.
The police action against Free happened directly after she was
going to make her allegations public which was followed shortly
after with a lawsuit. >> Wait, the police happened directly
after she was going >> Oh, I see. Oh, it was almost forgot
this was reported short with a lawsuit. It's pretty simple. If
the revenge wasn't real, it calls into question why the company
Mythic Talent was saying that it was. It makes me question how
hard Mythic Talent were pushing for litigation in the aftermath
of Tecton's ex-wife possibly coming out with
>> I like this angle because it makes it so that like,
hey, this is a company like, hey, Mythic Talent, what the was
going on here, man. Okay, I think this is smart. I think this
is very smart. Okay.
I wonder I wonder how much Listen, Shimu, listen. You got You
just had deposit. Okay. Five Msk bucks. Okay. You just got five
Msk bucks sent to you. All right. You keep going on Techone.
You're going to keep getting Msk bucks. You're going to keep
to go to the Miz Kids. Okay. You need somebody Shimu. You need
somebody in the Mizkiff cord. Okay. Wherever Msk's Discord is
showing these videos to people, getting them on board. All right.
Msk. Msk needs to start funding his ops or funding the the Alogs
of his ops. Okay, Msk. I know you got deep pockets. These people
made you want to yourself, right? Let's get him back. Couple
we get like a 150 subs to Shimoo's Patreon. All right, let's
do it. M kids, get on it. >> There's nothing you could
say definitively, though. Nobody involved in the lawsuit is willing
to clarify or confirm whether or not the revenge is real. Around
30 hours after reaching out to Mousashi, the CEO of Mythic Talent,
and others, somebody attempted to hack my Twitter account. There
were around 10 password resets sent all within the same minute.
Obviously, there's no telling who tried hacking my account whatsoever,
and it could have nothing to do with what I've been working on
at all. However, I felt it was worth mentioning and including
for posterity's sake. Page 14 contains a record request for the
police report that Pink filed, which was done by Fra's boyfriend,
Kerism. Then, anonymous account on Twitter, which you could assume
was Kerism, began posting the report, intimating that the report
was a lie. If it isn't a lie, and Free was guilty of this, it
would be a very odd thing to do to just start posting the incident
report about you. After the police report was posted two other
times on Twitter, on March 15th, Pink would send a cease and
assist to Free. And that's it for the allegations made in the
court filings. The rest of the pages I received were just reiterating
the allegations and the type of damages Pink was pursuing at
the time. If for some reason you'd like to see those, you can
let me know, but there's no new information in them that we didn't
already cover. Recently, Tech brought me up on stream implying
he's going to sue me possibly. He essentially started talking
about all the lawyers he has and then directly after this start
talking about me. And then I have a remote lawyer, a other lawyer,
and then two days ago I got another lawyer. So I have three lawyers
now. Finally, I think I have a lawyer that can actually do something
that I need, which is great, which is amazing.
Uh, you take a really
>> Yeah. I um there's this one guy there's this one guy,
his name's uh Shamu.
He made a uh a quote unquote hit piece on me. Oh god. My mod
linked me this one uh this one video cuz this guy's been skitso
posting about me on Twitter cuz he thinks it's going to do something.
Doesn't matter, bro. All my advertisers are Chinese and Japanese
and I don't talk to anybody. >> Guys, my advertisers are
Japanese and Chinese. I can as much as I want. I can be as into
lolly as I want.
You can't cancel me. I'm impervious. >> My channel relies
on me and me alone. The only person who can cancel me is me.
It doesn't matter if I were to somebody unless my account's permanu
has been streaming watching the second techone video or watching
the first Techone video. >> Oh, got some Techone
Crider in his PC with him. He was just like defending everything
and was saying that there was no assault charges against Mike
and all this sort of super autistic. He's super super authentic.
>> Okay.
Uh Jesus. Okay. Give me what? I need like two minutes to finish
the techone video and then >> I'll rewind that.
I just
funny. >> That's [__] hilarious. >> Have
zero interest in any sort of deplatforming of Techone. I wasn't
the one that made any of the allegations. His ex-wife and ex-girlfriend
did. Unlike you who constantly whines and complains about why
lefty Twitch streamers need to be banned, I personally want everyone
to have a platform and lessen bans as much as possible. I want
more crazy things online, not less. And the least amount of censorship
possible, >> right? And the good news is I'm a great guy.
Um, so this guy's accusing me of being a >> bro. This guy
seriously can't help himself from lying. I don't think Tik Ton
is a nun, nor have I ever called him one. He's referring to the
lolly eclipse we played earlier in the video. I posted the ones
where he talks about how their feet would taste and call him
a degenerate in a tweet. However, the main point being made that
Tech is a total hypocrite as he has tried to >> It's funny
that
Teto knows exactly
what he's being accused of. He knows that he's not being called
a but he knows that everybody around him will think he's being
called a so he's like leapt to that right away, right? Like I'm
I'm not I'm not It's like the guy's like no you made some weird
lolly comments. I didn't call you. I just said you made some
weird lolly comments. And he's like, "No, but all my friends
will think I'm a
so I'm going to say you called me."
Nope. >> Cancel and deplatform people for the exact same
behavior he did in the past. As for Teone suing me, I make it
very clear in both videos that both I and the viewers do not
know what happened in regards to these allegations, minus any
jokes being made in the video. I'm pretty certain I never accuse
him of being a either. Tecton is a public figure. I can talk
about the allegations being made against him. Period. I wanted
to make another video for the full court documents and touch
on a few things outside of his relationship scandals. My biggest
takeaways from looking into Techton is his willingness to be
totally dishonest. Even outside of the serious allegations from
his ex-wife and girlfriend, he is easily the fakest person I've
ever covered with lies. misrepresentation and hypocrisy sprinkled
everywhere when you just give a cursory look with the court filings
now public and my >> dude he just transparently lies everywhere.
It's actually
>> He might be like the worst at it. Like I don't know
how he made it this far at >> I didn't realize he had debates
over gacha meta. Like that is figured out by the most autistic
Chinese people alive like day one and you don't question it.
Why you haven't It's not up for debate, bro. And he literally
was like I destroyed these losers in two seconds and there's
like two of them talking to each other and they're like they
clearly just like like a they're clearly autistic, right? They're
clearly just like man I was just like pointing at the math and
he just said he beat me. It's so weird that he's like that he's
like this. It's like damn. >> My last video offering a
comprehensive timeline of events. I think I'm fairly well finished
here. Tecton has stated recently he plans to sue everyone. And
while I personally doubt this as he has made statements like
this in the past, if it happens, I will be pulling all the court
documents for that as well, unless he decides to sue me, I guess.
Cheers everyone. Peace. Hey guys, please hit like on the video
as it helps the channel and the algorithm. If you want to support
more content like this, you can do so at >> like, subscribe.
Go to go to Shamu's channel, like, subscribe. Okay.